what is happening there reject nation
greg and john back at it with a video
number four today apparently i was
getting all these messages being added
for this doctor strange tv spot there
was a couple that we already wanted to
cover and put up tomorrow so i was like
all right screw it i'm just gonna drop
all three in a final cut right now and
then we're gonna react to it but there's
one in particular here that is
apparently like insane it's short but
crazy but if you guys can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our review for
doctor strange is up uh next week let's
see what's going on
[Music]
rule number one of multiversal travel
you don't know anything
wow
stephen strange
the illuminati will see you now
wow
[Music]
oh i i totally missed this last trailer
man oh how cool
okay
cool
wow okay whoa that was uh that was a lot
to absorb i mean i heard people were
saying that one of these tv spots had a
living tribunal in it yeah that's what
that must be right there i heard all
about that a couple days ago i guess you
guys message me i i read it i read what
you guys were saying but man that that
is i gotta just play that one super
short one hold on a second i can't
believe that's out here right now what's
going on
stephen strange
the illuminati will see you now
[Music]
let's see what kind of doctor strange
you
[Laughter]
and it looks like he's even wearing like
the green suit right here yeah
like straight out of the x-men animated
series you got the yellow chair the way
it's hovering it doesn't move like a
wheelchair and then also it looks like
he's got the green suit on like he's
decked out like the x-men animated
series holy crap i just can't believe we
got ourselves the x-men animated series
version of it it might not it might just
be like aesthetically pulling from it
might not be directly pulled but then
you got captain carter who is directly
from the what if animated series yeah
and they got the revitalized x-men show
coming up like as much as that's not to
just bolster the show i'm sure they want
to get people thinking about that too
you know the other thing i'll add too is
he does say uh we'll see what kind of
doctor strange you are yeah and so it
seems like that this yeah this because
it is the illuminati so maybe they've
encountered like something
awful
is this one we can trust you know it's
like the doctor strange position he's in
is kind of like how loki was a
struggling variant in his own series and
it seems like he's like the a version of
doctor strange that is now going to be
judged instead of by the tva it's the
illuminati that's definitely peggy
carter she's fighting with wanda i don't
know what peggy carter can do again it's
one but sure why not
use that shield she's that vibranium
shields but she's got a jet pack which
is interesting i mean how did it end off
and what if thing about not being a
breakdown channel is you don't just have
time to research them
well i think okay yeah her story ended
the way how captain america's ended in
first avenger where she
after she fought like schumachorath i
think it was or a gargantos-like
creature she landed back in the present
in in the modern day time so she had
like the first avenger ending i imagine
that with that jet pack maybe she got
upgrades from iron man oh that would
make sense yeah maybe she's got some
nano nanotech jetpack or something like
that to augment her abilities wow we're
gonna see a live action captain carter
so excited dude i mean is this leaked or
something hold on i gotta go online make
sure we're not doing something that we
shouldn't be doing
we will see what kind of doctor strange
you are
marvel studios doctor strange no i mean
at the end of this it says in theaters
on friday i mean yeah so there must be a
real just kind of it's just a foreign
spot i guess i'm just baffled that it's
actually in the in the tv spot itself
well see the things like this now strike
me as being very strategic i'm like yeah
this seems like they are confirming some
big stuff and you know you get that shot
too of american chavez being like
multiversal travel man you don't know
what you're doing i don't even remember
the first trailer we saw
but i wonder something like this makes
me wonder if they're willing to show us
this what else is waiting because yeah i
mean from spider-man no way home i think
they probably learned the the partial
value in giving us a few bones that were
like really heavily anticipating and so
yeah like these professor x teases seem
like exactly that but yeah seeing this
and seeing the living tribunal and all
that it makes me wonder what craziness
that's gonna blow our minds is waiting
beyond these because also too i mean
these these illuminati uh shots could be
from later on in the movie but it seems
like they often pull from early in the
movie so it really makes me fascinated
to know how they're going to enter the
plot and how much they're going to
interject throughout i mean they got to
probably be like the first half of act
two yeah what i imagine that it's at the
imagery is just so gosh darn beautiful
to have here the living tribunal are
like the cosmic judiciary of the
universe i think is the best way to
categorize them if you've read the
infinity gauntlet comic book too they
acquitted thanos of his crimes hey
thanos was right and then also would
like the living tribunal if i'm not
mistaken i remembered they were i think
they were supposed to originally be
featured in infinity war i believe in
infinity war they did want to have some
type of trial to really pull from the
infinity gauntlet comic book there is a
head in the loki series i remember that
easter egg in the loki series when they
go to that planet where all the loki's
are abandoned or where that void
situation i don't remember the name yeah
that there is a there is a living
tribunal head there so that was an
easter egg for it and michael waldron
who was the showrunner for that is the
one who was writing this yeah i do
wonder what they'd be playing
here like it just seems like there's so
much going on they got to be like a
setup for it if you got the illuminati
in here and then a clear shot of what is
easily monica rambo not tom cruise as
superior iron man never jump off that
train
just die on that hill i mean yeah it
makes you wonder because they've
introduced so many like elder god type
characters or characters who have a more
godly more removed more powerful status
but who also for various reasons do or
don't intervene and it's like you're
getting the illuminati which is another
version of that and then to have the
living tribunal actually show up it
makes me wonder if that could be
something where it's like we are going
to pierce like well beyond the realm of
of who are the powers that be in the
universe because i feel like almost
that's been part of the theme of phase
four is shattering the illusion of all
the different powers that be but it
seems like there's got to be at least
one or a triple-headed one or something
at the end of all that and i'm curious
to see how they expand on that with this
movie too this is wild absolutely i mean
america's shop has said some fun things
in the beginning
multiverse you don't know what you're
doing i don't remember what you said
there but guys uh this is mind-blowing
this is mind-blowing we're getting so
much doctor strange goodies right now
and we see this on monday so we i think
the embargo lifts on tuesday it's gonna
be a very late night uh for us so we're
gonna have to film it and then of course
do our review right out of the theater
which is always a little daunting at a
premiere because you gotta wait for
everyone to clear out before you start
talking about things place where you
don't get terrible audio yeah it's gonna
be a fun time and i i really hope that
you guys tune in for that because this
movie looks like just one hell of a wild
ride all right well thanks for being
here i'll talk to you guys soon
you